ja willkommen zur aktuellen Sitzung in
der wir es mit dem Philosophen Moses
Mendelssohn zu tun haben werden ein ganz
wichtiger deutscher Philosoph der
Aufklärung der eine Schrift verfasst hat
ein Aufsatz über die Frage was heißt
aufklären im Jahr 1784 und so seine gute
Mensch aus und
da sehen sie das
Titelbild das Titelblatt der
Berlinischen Monatsschrift
in der diese Aufsatz erschien ich möchte
jetzt ein bisschen was zum historischen
Kontext sagen zum
problemkontext in dem diese Aufsatz von
Moses erschienen ist und zwar erschien
im Jahr davor 1783 in dieser Zeit in
dieser berlinischen Monatsschrift ein
Aufsatz mit dem Titel vor gesagt die
Geistlichen nicht mehr bei der
Vollziehung der Ehen zu bemühen die
Berlinische Monatsschrift war ein Organ
ein
Publikationsorgan einer
aufgeklärten Berliner Gesellschaft
wo viele berühmte Personen dann auch in
diesem Organ veröffentlicht haben unter
anderem auch Immanuel Kant aber auch
viele heute nicht mehr so bekannte nicht
nur Philosophen sondern eben auch
Theologen und
diese Aufsatz dieser Vorschlag dass die
Geistlichen also kirchliche Kontexte
nicht mehr bei der Ehe relevant sein
sollten der Verstand sich eben als ein
Plädoyer für die zivile und er enthielt
einen Passus
den ich zitiere für aufgeklärte Menschen
bedarf es doch wohl all der Zeremonien
nicht also das war natürlich eine
provokative these der damaligen Zeit wo
die Religion Kirche auch bei der eh noch
eine viel größere Rolle gespielt hat als
heutzutage und der Theologe Johann
Friedrich Zöllner ich sagte ja auch
Theologen haben in dieser berlinischen
monatschrift veröffentlicht der sah sich
dadurch herausgefordert und er
veröffentlichte im selben Jahr nur
wenige Zeit später ein Beitrag auch in
dieser berlinischen monatschrift mit dem
Titel oder der Frage ist es ratsam das
Ehebündnis nicht ferner durch die
religionieren also durch die Religion zu
bestätigen und ihren Ausdruck zu
vermitteln der ehe er verteidigte damit
die kirchliche Ehe
und er schrieb in einer Anmerkung ganz
beiläufig die man auch leicht übersehen
kann was ist Aufklärung an der bezog
sich auf diesen Passus der oben für
aufgeklärte Bedarf ist doch wohl all der
Zeremonien nicht was ist Aufklärung
diese Frage die Bein also wichtig ist
als was es Wahrheit sollte doch wohl
beantwortet werden jemand aufzuklären
anfingen und noch habe ich sie nirgends
beantwortet gefunden das war dann der
Ausgangspunkt für viele Schriften wie
zum Beispiel von Moses Mendelssohn die
versuchten den Begriff der Aufklärung zu
definieren auch Immanuel Kant hat es
dann im selben Jahr wie Moses Mädels
versucht
so sieht jetzt dieses
dieses Blatt aus dieses Aufsatzes und
hier unten sieht man diese unscheinbare
Anmerkung mit der Frage was ist
Aufklärung die eben Anlass für ganz
verschiedene Schriften zu beantworten
dieser Frage in der Folge gegeben hat ja
jetzt kommen wir zur Moses Mendelssohn
und er hat eben ein Aufsatz geschrieben
über die Frage was heißt Aufklärer hat
sich darauf bezogen auf diese Debatte
und ich bringe jetzt ein paar Zitate aus
dieser Schrift wo ich wichtige Passagen
fett markiert hat er schreibt die Worte
Aufklärung Kultur Bildung sind in
unserer Sprache der deutschen Sprache
noch neu Ankömmlinge es gehören vor der
Hand los zu büchersprache der gemeine
Haufe versteht sie kaum also es handelt
sich praktisch nur im intellektuelle
Schrift Begriffe sprich Schrift
Verwendung dieser Worte die noch kein
Eingang in die Alltagsprache gefunden
haben weil sie sind letztendlich nicht
lebensweltlich wirklich verankert und
deswegen möchte
die Grenzen derselben dieser drei Wörter
festsetzen möchte Begriffe definieren
das heißt ja auch definieren die Grenzen
bestimmen
ein weiteres wichtiges Zitat ist dass er
sagt Bildung Kultur und Aufklärung sind
Modifikationen des geselligen Lebens
also sie beziehen sich nicht auf
abstrakte Spekulationen sondern auf die
Lebenswelt auf den Alltag und er
unterscheidet jetzt die Bildung in zwei
Formen die Bildung kann man zu teilen
zwischen Kultur und Aufklärung jene das
ist natürlich die Kultur die geht mir
auf das praktische aber die betrifft
Fertigkeit Fleiß Geschicklichkeit
und die Aufklärung die geht eher auf das
theoretische die vernünftige Erkenntnis
und das Nachdenken kann also eher die
abstraktere Form aber die ist auch auf
das gesellige Leben wir ja oben sagt
bezogen auf die Lebenswelt so kann man
sich jetzt die Unterscheidung genauer
vorstellen also bildungserfällten
Kulturen Aufklärung die er bestimmt dann
die Kultur mit anderen Begriffen um sie
abzugrenzen von der Aufklärung Praxis
gehören dazu Sittlichkeit gehört dazu
Virtuosität also auch sowas wie Ästhetik
kommt zur Kultur und auf der anderen
Seite die Aufklärung
ähnelt der Theorie ist ja viel mit der
Betrachtung der Reflexion gemeinsam mit
der Erkenntnis und auch mit der Kritik
das sind die
entsprechenden Gegenbegriffe er möchte
aber Kulturen Aufklärung nicht
entgegensetzen sondern sie sind
aufeinander bezogen im Begriff der
Bildung Bildung ist natürlich auch ein
ganz wichtiger Begriff
er bringt dann am Ende seines Aufsatzes
noch ein sehr interessanten Part wo er
auch die Probleme von Aufklärung
thematisiert also die edler ihre Blüte
die von Kultur und Aufklärung desto
abscheulicher in ihre Verwesung
und Verderbtheit das heißt es gibt auch
die Möglichkeit dass es nicht gelingt
die Gesellschaft aufzuklären und die
Kultur voranzubringen er sagt
missbrauchte Aufklärung schwächt des
moralisch Gefühl für zu hart sind
Egoismus irreligion und Anarchie also
auch Aufklärung kann missbraucht werden
und Missbrauch der Kultur auf der
anderen Seite erzeugt Üblichkeit
gleißnerei Weichlichkeit aber glauben
und Sklaverei also man muss Ganztag
aufpassen mit diesen Formen der Bildung
mit Kulturen Aufklärung in ihrem guten
Zustand sind sie sehr sehr schätzenswert
aber wenn sie falsch gebraucht werden
dann kann es zu großen Problemen führen
und das führt natürlich auch schon zur
Dialektik der Aufklärung auf die Hocker
monatorno dann im 20 Jahrhundert
hingewiesen haben ja
so ist es Mendelssohn er wünscht sich
oder sagt das Aufklärung und Kultur mit
gleichen Schritten fortgehen sollen
damit sie die Korruption also die innere
Zerstörung bestimmter Strukturen
natürlich auch das Zusammenlebens
verhindern können und er spricht sogar
auch von der Bildung einer Nation die
auskultur und Aufklärung
zusammengesetzt sein sollte es also
natürlich auch normatives Ideal der
Begriff der Bildung wo eben Aufklärung
und Kultur gelingen und nicht scheitern
auch das ist wie er sagt möglich
in der nächsten Folge die Seminars auf
filocast behandeln wir Immanuel Kant
auch er hat versucht die Frage zu
beantworten was ist Aufklärung auch er
hat sich durch diese Fußnote diese kurze
Anmerkung von Söllner provoziert oder
herausgefordert gesehen oder animiert
gesehen
genauer zu bestimmen was Aufklärung ist
und hier sieht man auch in der
Berlinischen Monatsschrift 1784
das Titelbild seines Beitrags dann
bedanke ich mich vielmals für die
Aufmerksamkeit und freue mich auf eine
nächste Sitzung gerne auch mit Kommentar
und dann auf YouTube